Yohan good sex in Paris
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas de le dire vous êtes de
nouvelles coqueluche d'Hollywood vous
avez joué avec Tom Cruise dans
collatéral vous avez remporté un Oscar
pour Ray le film bio de sur Ray Charles
vous allez tourner avec Coline Farrell
dans Miami Vice et votre deuxième disque
est en tête du Top
US Jamie Fox
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
alors
vous êtes le premier acteur du monde à
avoir reçu un Oscar et vous dites
j'apprends à me contrôler à dompter
cette bête qui est l'Oscar à ne pas
considérer ça comme une revanche
je suis arrivé au sommet
alors ce qu'il faut c'est
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
cela revenir à la case de départ et voir
ce qu'on peut faire après parce qu'il y
a une vie après l'Oscar voir un petit
peu quel nouveau sommeil quel nouveau
défi sans avoir la grosse tête alors
vous dites le scarm tapait spa c'est
même plutôt l'inverse il faut donc avoir
des gens autour de toi qui te mettent
des claques et vous dès que vous dérapez
un peu il y a votre sœur il y a votre
sœur qui vous qui vous corrige quoi
la petite sœur elle est à peu près comme
ça
un immense cœur et puis elle s'occupe
bien de moi elle me dit toujours la
vérité surtout en fait vous faites très
attention à pas devenir comme le
personnage de votre film avec Oliver
Stone l'enfer du dimanche quoi
vous avez travaillé avec
Ludacris Busta Rhymes Pharrell Williams
évidemment de goldiger voilà et il y a
beaucoup de chansons d'inspiration
gospel
que j'ai grandi moi et puis il y a une
chanson qui est dédiée à ma fille qui
m'a accompagné aux Oscars
elle a 12 ans elle grandit chaque jour
alors il y a beaucoup de sexe dans ce
disque quand même beaucoup de sexe c'est
un peu c'est un peu des chansons c'est
des chansons pour chambre à coucher un
peu non
la musique soit c'est en boîte de nuit
soit dans la chambre à coucher
moi je préfère le lit mais c'est vrai
que quand vous étiez
quand vous étiez plus jeune vous vous
appeliez des filles au téléphone et vous
leur faisiez écouter des disques au
téléphone pour les draguer ça je savais
pas c'est énorme
quand j'étais quand j'étais gamin alors
je les appel ais effectivement et puis
je peux
[Musique]
et c'est comme ça que j'ai appris
figurez-vous advenir romantique moi-même
avec les filles alors voilà vous êtes
numéro 1 au top US mais la seule ombre
au tableau c'est que votre grand-mère
qui vous avez poussé dans la voie de la
de la musique et décédé avant cette
reconnaissance énorme que vous avez
maintenant quoi
de 23 octobre 2004 qu'elle est décédée
mais elle avait quand même 95 ans et
puis il faut se rappeler quand même
depuis que j'étais tout petit elle avait
consacrée toute sa vie à mon existence
c'est une chose que j'ai apprise lorsque
ma fille est née ben j'ai vécu pour
l'existence de ma fille c'était très
beau parce que ma grand-mère et moi nous
étions très proches elle vivait avec moi
lorsque
vous avez 83 ans on était toujours
ensemble donc c'était triste bien sûr
mais en même temps le moment était venu
pour elle d'aller ailleurs en fait vous
avez été abandonné par vos parents quand
vous étiez très jeune
à 7 mois j'ai été adopté
par ses copains mais c'était une date
une très belle relation avec mes parents
adoptifs à ce que je n'étais pas assez
âgé pour connaître l'existence même de
mes parents biologiques donc c'était mes
seuls parents finalement alors votre
vrai nom c'est Eric Morlon Bishop
vous avez commencé dans le circuit des
cabarets du stand-up vous avez décidé de
vous inscrire au casting et ce qui est
très drôle en fait c'est que pour être
sûr d'avoir du boulot il s'inscrivait
dans les castings avec plusieurs
identités différentes alors il y en a
une c'était Éric Morlon c'était Jamie
Fox
NIGHT Parce qu'il y avait des soirées
amateurs
ou les noms étaient choisis au hasard
dans une liste alors je vais donner
plusieurs noms du genre Stacy green
principal Jamie Fox pourquoi c'est non
là parce que il y aurait deux filles et
50 mecs dans la liste donc on prenait
toujours les filles et Jimmy ça faisait
un nom de fille donc c'est pour ça que
je comprenais et Fox et Fox c'est à
cause de Redfox qui était un comique
connu
afro-américain voilà alors d'abord je
vais être célèbre à la télévision en 95
j'ai eu un album finalement
qui a pas très bien marché d'ailleurs
vous dites si j'avais eu du succès
j'aurais jamais eu l'Oscar et puis
ensuite il y a eu cette fameuse émission
aux Etats-Unis le Jamie Fox show qui a
été un gros gros succès sur sur
Warhammer et ensuite je vais appris à
faire du cinéma en fait en regardant des
films de Denzel Washington ou de Al
Pacino hein
le cinéma le jeu d'acteur c'est de
limitation donc moi j'imitais mes
acteurs favoris Al Pacino Denzel
Washington j'essaie d'apprendre en les
regardant de sorte que lorsque je me
suis retrouvé devant ou du plus haut
derrière la caméra j'ai essayé de faire
la même chose ensuite il y a eu Ali avec
Will Smith collatéral avec Tom Cruise
Rey évidemment le fameux rail la vie de
Ray Charles et alors Eddie Murphy vous a
dit qu'on voulait parler du film en fait
exactement les mêmes mâchoires que Ray
Charles il suffit de mettre les lunettes
et ça fera la blague quoi
[Applaudissements]
au cinéma sur le tournage j'avais toute
la journée les paupières collées même
pendant les
déjeuner quoi
les paupières collées quelquefois me
laisser comme ça sur le plateau en
oubliant que j'y voyais rien moi avec
ses paupières collées mais c'était
nécessaire de faire ça pour vraiment me
mettre dans la peau du personnage
pourquoi parce que je ne pouvais pas
tricher de même que Ray Charles ne
pouvait vraiment pas voir lorsque je
faisais la musique et bien on s'en
rendait compte
cette difficulté le fait que j'avais les
yeux vraiment fermés alors vous dites
l'Oscar attire les femmes mûres et
finalement c'est tant mieux parce que
vous aimez pas tellement les minettes
les filles jeunes vous dites pour qu'une
femme séduisent vaut mieux qu'elle sache
ce qui s'est passé en 1983 et qu'elle
possède quelques disques de Prince
on rencontre des gamines qui vous parle
de choses trop fraîches trop récente que
je ne connais plus moi j'ai bien parlé
de mes classiques à moi de prince de
belge
et quand elles sont trop jeunes elles
connaissent pas elles connaissent pas
donc je dis pas que
j'aime pas le mot mur plutôt
expérimenté quel âge quel âge 60 65
30 jusqu'à 50 peut-être j'avais appelé
ma mère
un peu dépassé
vous avez déclaré en ce moment il ne me
manque que l'amour vous n'avez pas
d'amour en ce moment
vivre une vie de célibataire un petit
peu c'est bien la plupart de mes amis
lorsqu'ils arrivent à un certain stade
de leur existence de leur carrière il se
marie bien moi j'ai envie de rester
célibataire envie d'offrir des diamants
à quelqu'un d'autre que toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va voir si vous parlez français on va
faire une interview parlez-vous français
est-ce qu'on me voyant vous avez eu un
sentiment de déjà-vu Yes Men in Black
true
est-ce que vous cherchez une fiancée
non non
est-ce que vous êtes blasé par votre
métier
ah non est-ce que vous avez envie de
baiser
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que vous aimez le coq aux
vins Wiko
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous faites vous faites quoi après
l'émission est-ce que vous avez
rendez-vous
j'ai un rendez-vous Jamie est-ce que
vous avez déjà fait ménage à toi
est-ce que vous trouvez que les
Françaises sont des femmes fatales
oui oui
il parle bien français il y a plus tard
à dire à une femme qui vous plaît et que
vous connaissez à peine voulez-vous
coucher avec moi ce soir
[Applaudissements]
vous aviez sur la France avant de venir
romantique
est-ce que lorsqu'il vous arrive un
petit malheur dans la vie vous dites
c'est la vie
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu